look at the chinks wearing the [__]
American [__] hats and [__] yes
because those CHS are more americ do you
anyone have any launch codes day to I
don't think anyone has
noticed it's like that show The
Americans but instead of the Russians
and blend it in it's just Asians doing
this with tape their eyes trying to make
them round you know me just every
average Joel
what I'm sorry Frozen you know me I
picked myself up by bootstrap go to
construction site I I pick myself up by
my sandal straps and I go to work I take
my bag lunch to work I look up box score
for Philly game listen I bind my wife's
feet one foot at a time just like
American so Roy how you think the bird's
going to do this year I don't know John
John it's like John
Cho H he's even trying to he's even
calling Sports talk shows to blend in
yeah this is Mike Francis how you doing
you're you're on the line John John from
Long Island City how you doing yeah I'm
wondering how you think Mech going to do
this year they have weak pitching
rotation I'll hang up let you answer I
want to hang up he my question first
time wrong
time
baa bu Howard Devil Bird is calling him
jurry six
PR you know me I'm a real ham and
Egger oh my
god oh
[__] sorry you hear this new stey damn
box set so good many deep cut many many
deep cut anybody else watching Yost
Stone I hear new series a season of Boys
the boys coming out soon they're
excited oh [__] try this I make beef
jerky with
[Laughter]
Tabasco oh God damn oh
[__] okay it probably shouldn't have
done that the whole time with this woman
on the screen oh no because now they're
going to think that this that's cuz you
know we're going to clip this now now
the independent's going to be like no
they're making fun of this Asian woman
the independent we're making fun of that
Asian woman you're looking at that
particular one we're making fun of her
for being so Asian taking wife on Cru
Royal Caribbean next month got very good
price Diamond status there they are with
that nobody notices I just found the guy
Roy they sent him to okay thank you nice
camouflage
camouflage oh [__] Asians undercover
here we go this is
them hey Bobby look look I'm
American I think I'll use my credit card
do you guys have anything non-dairy
anything GL they're getting good he
stole he stole that bit from South Park
they're getting good they're getting
good guys you stole that line word for
word though remember the South Park one
that was a old school one the DodgeBall
episode like I would like to use my
credit card and they're
like mocking us see and that's the
difference between us and the rest of
the world is that if Chinese people were
imitating us like this we live
hysterically like that's [__] funny
yeah